so at some
point his linear thrust has an end point
it doesn't go on
adding his
mind in his intention to
attack yes on this
plane but it has a range to it okay it's
not an abstract
add for
okay so here in other words here's his
spinal displacement right it has a place
where it is trying to get
to so we'll represent that by
his by this hand pushing okay and you
pretend on there got it and you would
push like you normally do for spinal
displacement so it has the end now it it
gets intense to that end it's increasing
pressure and then once it passes that in
it starts to go off you get it and
that's because it's
fine um in other words stay there if I
was boom I was to push him it would
eventually
stop in other words if he gets out of
the way boom it it doesn't keep
going like in iido la la land do you
guys understand that there is an end
point and so what I want to understand
is at that end
point the power that I feel in his hands
is actually going to be reduced and the
mechanical advantage of being at the
distal end of the lever is going to
become mine if I can get to that end
point of his linear thrust trying to
lift his hands up in the power Arc of
his limit of his linear thrust it makes
the hands heavy you guys got that and
you see that in your body when you're
like whoa that's the hands heavy you're
getting weighted in the back foot you
might feel it in your shoulder you might
have to bend your elbow you might have
to take a big circle all those are your
two in close okay you want to feel where
it's light
nothing you move where it's
light you move where it's light so just
a very simple we're staying on the line
you move where it's
light light
no doesn't take any effort so it doesn't
have to take this angle or any variation
let me go any
variation where the outer deltoid starts
to be part of the structural integrity
so from here on this is all not
Marshall UK is letting you do
that or change the
M here he's got closer to me and I'm
trying to absorb the Y energy in my
elbow I just want my hand to go
up and I can do it if I stay at the edge
of his linear Force vector
of course space like how far out I am is
a matter of space time so you can do it
without even
moving it's when you do
it you do big yes that'll
work it is small
but I am trying not to feel his
pressure not here and I'm trying not to
compensate for it in any
way okay try to so Point number one is
the technique does not happen within the
power Arc of the UK okay it happens at
the edge of the power Arc the edge of
the power Arc is a space time it's not
just the space
okay um I don't want to have any lateral
movement because I don't want to utilize
the deltoid the outer deltoid all right
here's the second Point uh the lifting
of the arm is never like this I let it
be like that so we just simplify the
first lesson but we already know that
the arm has to pass through the
phases okay it's not going to be as big
a phase as you're used to so come to
this
side in other words I'm not going to go
get on CH on J I'm not going to do that
it's very small it's very
small very small that was
it this
one not this one you see that just very
small Slow Down slow down slow down
that way if you pay attention that's how
I pass this wrist here okay if I kept
making it big I'm going to turn him
because he keeps his palms it's going to
turn him you see and he's not going to
be there so it's a very small
inside and that means at the end then
it's not going to be pal
up it's Jon h okay so the elbows
down and I'm going to do this
version going forward so you can feel
how you are going around his
hands and allowing when you work at that
edge of his power Arc and you do this
movement you allow the center to come
underneath it but not the top of his
body and that's why I can keep walking
forward he's still pushing me there's
pressure there or I just go around that
pressure on the top side of this
careful in this that you don't get the
deltoid because you over exaggerate get
on and Cheon it's very
small very
small okay let's try it
just okay that that is the of course
there's an external to aikido's
architecture that's the external
um most people they don't even do that
but if you are working on it and you
only have the
external you you end up looking like
this on
you to me you to me you look like
this I'll try to make it look like a a
ferite okay an external
ferite well what if I asked you to do it
like
this you couldn't do it
couldn't do
it and if you looked at the two versions
there's way less tension in the body in
the second
version and most
importantly there's way
more tilt in his body because his Center
can come more
forward and that's where the throw
happens because the throw is a matter of
his line of
gravity moving
rearward and falling outside his Bas of
support that's why he falls but the
Marshall application is the reason he
doesn't stick his feet back underneath
his line of gravity is because they're
occupied with forward progress
okay and that's the difference so when I
go stiff you pay attention you see how I
stop him from coming his whole body
stops him from coming in and then I just
enter and
push but on the other one it's so soft
look
how much it comes in and most
importantly it's inertia is pinning it
in
place
okay so I can't you have to develop the
internal to do this I know it happens
out at the edge of the power Arc I know
I don't use the deltoids I know I do
have an external spiral of the
arm um but there's still a matter of
young aspect being
internalized alchemically treated by
being bounced off the
ground and then admitted in this case at
a higher y value than the contact point
at the contact point But at the center
it's allowed to keep going
in okay and I don't want to keep it out
and tension keeps it
out so as we do the
throw and I would like for you to play
with different versions okay different
tensions but your goal should ultimately
be as you
learn to chase the Marshall aspect that
I must pre occupy his feet with the
forward inertia and its metric is how
far the center comes
forward of the shoulders before I start
pushing on him yes if you push on
someone and they're trained they'll
leave their feet there cuz they're
getting ready for the back breakfall but
it's before I start pushing on them how
much shoulder to to Center Center
gravity angle changes that's that's what
you're looking for as you do this
technique okay that's what you're
looking
for okay try
it okay and another internal aspect
is that from wherever I'm touching I can
touch something else in his body I can
affect his body we've been discussing
this that that constant 90° modulation
can't really be done externally it has
to to be done internally okay and that
ability for that constant 90° modulation
I can use it in different ways so I know
martially I want to change the center of
gravity shoulder relationship okay and I
know that I want his feet occupied with
his forward
inertia when I do the throw I'm not
going to just Rel on those
physics that he can't get his feed back
under him let's move this
way okay because highly super athletic
people can do it so I'm going to this is
going to represent occupying him with
forward inertia this this shoulder plane
is good to go okay and I'm going to push
you're going to you're going to do your
monkey get your feet back under you
okay
I think you could do it without pulling
your Center up I know it's weird but
you'll be able to do it you don't have
to give me that much that doesn't happen
in the technique okay
good so what I'm going to do is on this
forward hand although it is pushing this
way taking the shoulder further out of
the same vertical plane with the center
it's pushing down don't don't lean there
you go okay it's not just going this
way it is going that way but there's a
downward to it on his feet
okay and that stops his
feet from being able to go back under
him so here I am I'm going completely
over it and affecting the shoulders but
he can move his feet
backwards here's that same angle
physical angle but you'll feel that you
feel that pressure on your feet now okay
and so now I'll just leave this amount
of pressure and you move your feet
backwards and you'll see it's a little
harder for him okay and every movement
that he tries to make to get his feet
back under him I keep 90° modulation on
that and it adds to the throat okay so
in other words don't come over the top
your you just keep knocking it Knocking
him down you have to pin is you feel the
pin
now your feet get pinned and the only
way I can do that is with the internal
skill
you feel it on your feet not just
Che on your
feet so the second I going through and
around and I get any
see any angle variation between the
shoulder plane and the center plane once
I get that I now start attacking the
feet you feel that okay that's what I'm
attacking so you pay attention there's a
more of a downward miss a
downward
down okay try it
all right so in in the
uh Tenon
version that I do again remember you're
going to work the diagonals if he's got
a
linear thrust energy you you always work
the diagonals to start the fight
rotating just in his desire to complete
that linear thrust okay um that so even
if you do the tencom version you can't
tenom from
here you have to first
enter you can do uh an ashido ten
conversion so that's the one that I did
so I came this
way but whatever your goal
is once you start SP we're rotating the
overall pairing the overall UK Dynamic
you want to try to get that centrifugal
energy because it is a throw and we
utilize the centrifugal energy um to add
to all the mechanics that we just went
over okay so as I go just relax let go
as I'm moving over
here I start that centrifugal energy and
I can now do everything that I just did
on that line there which is where that
centrifical energy is is going to pull
in
okay the hard part of this is that once
you start a turn people tend to use
their arms to turn and now you have your
deltoid doing this
thing so you have to keep your arm in
the same straight position the same
straight
position and you do the
turn don't come
side don't try to bring them in
and L so you have to still stay at the
edge of the power
Arc and
thech and the technique because you've
added another Force the centrifugal
force it should all become easier but
don't don't capitalize upon the
centrifical energy there's still the
internal aspect that you're doing
[Music]
okay try it
okay so
um
again there is always a relationship
ship
between ukmi the receiving and what it
and what is being
received
um this is why both my nag waza looks
different and my UK my ukes look
different they fall differently
okay um trying to do my Nag waza
on the standard Emi
is it's not doable you're either going
to hurt
someone
um or you're just not going to do the
technique so you don't hurt them
okay uh or or and even in not doing the
technique you could also not do the
technique because you have to change the
technique because they change the energy
cue as you K okay they're going to
change the energy
Cube so we know how this technique
functions
marshy there is going to be the center
of gravity is taken forward and out of
the same vertical plane with the
shoulders
okay so if he's here and I do
that
okay and he's got to do a back RF fall
now
okay and we'll do it
again and he ended up doing what did you
do I feel like I had to take a step you
took a step
okay
um can you take a step in the
technique no okay why because my feet
are his feet are preoccupied with the
forward iner and they're being pinned
okay so let's add that okay got it so
here's the plane and now
it's and you can see now that you're
falling flatter and flatter as we go
okay um and that's nowhere near the
inertial values of the of the technique
okay so what usually happens is because
again Sean has a lot of years of a lot
of early years of fedorite training okay
and what you get in the beginning just
like kids it kind of sticks deeper okay
so when you
do your back rate fall you're you want
to always bring your hips back in
alignment with your shoulders okay uh
don't do the Contracting Center back
breakfall which I know you can do under
idealized conditions but always in the
technique you do the
bonai um back breakfall which requires
the the shoulders and the hips to come
back in alignment okay so you just do a
normal back
rle there you go
Okay so if I were to put him in this
position and now he does that normal
back Rak fall you'll see that he puts
his hips back underneath his shoulders
and the
B and the bom ey back breakfall this one
is by far better than the standard IAI
back breakfall okay because in the
standard I kback breakfall they will sit
their butt back behind their shoulders
do you see and then they won't go to the
side they just go straight by
okay so if you are in an a standard IAI
dojo and you're going to put your butt
behind your shoulders do you see
that it's going to be very hard to take
this youi okay uh if you're even a bonai
uh person you're going to also have a
hard time we're going to have to train
slow and you're going to do this you see
that and then you go back
now the person that is going to try to
get their hips either behind their
shoulders in standard IAI or in
alignment with their shoulders with
bonai they know they in their mind they
know they have to do that so what they
start to do is less and less allow for
the deplaning of the shoulders and the
hips do you see and they start resisting
the
technique okay this is not Emi that it
is resistance you're countering the
technique the technique is allowing your
hips to go forward you're like no I'm
going to counter it uh by not letting
myself go forward
okay
um and so let's say I'm I'm here here
you're grabbing okay and I go and he is
not going to let those hips go forward
but if you pay
attention as my arm goes
up you
see you you have to be able to get
closer to me you see that and so there's
that tilt okay you got it and now if I
do this in the timing you'd have this
going and you have no means of uh you
still countered it did everyone see
right what did he do Taylor he turned he
turned around the technique you see
which is possible going slow because he
can uh counter the inertia but going
fast which I'm going here do you see and
this all goes
into and then he falls flat okay you do
that over and over they're going to stop
coming in it just aren't going to like
it
okay now to answer your question
what was happening is as Tristan's
having you here and you take your hips
back into that PL the wrist gets exposed
you see and so that's why you're feeling
the
need that would be a way like okay I
can't practice this K on this he changed
the technique now I have to change the
technique I end up in the N okay and
that's what you were feeling okay if we
watch
Tristan's
Uki because his Center stays engaged as
I project the cooku projection through
him he rides that energy and it gets
over this
mechanical what seems impossible to the
bonai or the IAI how do I get down from
here do do you get it and if that's why
he's he's so springy he's so springy
brings out now if you watch his feet
right they don't step cuz he can't step
but he still finds the fault his feet
stay where they are
okay
um and I don't think you can practice
this technique on the other person
that's doing the other ukemi okay and
because you're in that dilemma okay I'm
going to hurt you or I don't hurt you in
other words I I go slow enough to allow
you to counter the inertia and the
momentum uh but now I have to do a
different technique I have to do Niko
instead of the K okay to me that's very
problematic because these are not
Marshall techniques these are um
energetic techniques and within them you
are working those purification rituals
of alchemically modifying Yang aspect so
a better
solution is to teach them thei okay and
so what we do is he's going to lean back
okay and you're going to give me all
your weight give me your weight here
give it to me give it to me and that is
very scary for a lot of people give it
to me give it to me give it to me give
it to me relax give me all your weight
and then come back
up okay you have to get them used to
that and because it is a fear
getting your hips back behind your
shoulders getting your hips even with
your shoulders is a fear response okay
so you have to give me it I'm going to
hold you I'm not going to let you drop
give it more relax relax get all this
tension out I'm holding
you more and come
up okay so if
I had Tristan in that
position I have all his weight he'll
still find his fall or you when I let go
you find your
fall okay or I do that to you you're not
going to find it and this is experiment
you could do in your own Gojo let
somebody give you all their weight and
go find the fall and you'll see they
won't find the fall okay um so but you
have to get there that would be the
first exercise okay um once they can get
to where they give up all their
weight then
let him have some of the weight back and
this is like it's a poison I'm giving
back to him but he he can't find it
without some fear being taken off okay
so give me all your
weight okay and take back some and now I
want you to uh pretend I'm going to
punch you in the middle of the Fall find
your back foot
I want you to to think about hitting
this hand first forget that foot this
hand first give me your weight take back
some weight that hand first turn your
head and look at that
hand
better again look at the
hand I'm going to punch
you come on
turn your whole
body in the Thro
tight get
ready okay better but if you're honest
you can feel like that that's a lot
of concentration okay uh the next thing
you want to do after they get
comfortable with that is you kind in the
technique you just go slow so you're
getting that problem you see and you'll
just go come forward forward forward
okay do the same drill when you feel my
pressure okay make him leave his hips
forward forward St there don't
turn and you're going to do the same
drill from here so it's this
hand there you
go relax
okay good it's this
hand you can see now his hips are
staying forward of his shoulders okay
and he just got to get used to it in
terms of fear has to be reconciled in
terms of the reconciliation of fear is a
skill okay and all skills require
repetitions